nous faisons la connaissance de nos
charmants deux voisines ça fera estime à
un coup de fil plus tard nous sommes
assurés d'avoir un lit pour dormir à
notre arrivée
grâce à son charisme mots amers ylmaz a
fait le tour du monde sans argent dans
ses poches
dans un monde où tout tourne autour de
l'argent partir découvrir le monde sans
un sou et être heureux pendant 80 jours
sans un sou en poche c'est quelque chose
de magique
salutations surnommé le voyage est
soumis sont amers ylmaz et son acolyte
ont voulu prouver qu'on peut se nourrir
se loger et se déplacer avec la
générosité des autres
cette idée un peu farfelue a été
documentée dans un film sorti en 2015
on a les pattes avec nos couchage pas de
tonte pas de médicaments et pas d'argent
donc c'était un choix important de ne
pas prendre de sacs de couchage parce
qu'on n'avait pas cette option de dormir
dehors
nous allons vous offrir une chambre
sorti complètement transformé de son
périple le français d'origine turque
admet avoir eu faim à l'occasion force
alors qu'il était dans une zone déserte
parce que généralement la bonté venait
assez rapidement même pour les
déplacements en avion du celtic et il
faut avouer que les réseaux sociaux nous
ont aidés et après ça s'est emballé
voilà plein de gens voulaient lui offrir
le billet d'avion il faut que d'aller à
san francisco où quelque part dans
l'ouest américain
mais pour arriver à ses fins
l'aventurier a dû être persuasif il faut
convaincre les gens de notre bonne
volonté et de leur donner confiance
parce que c'est pas évident de prendre
quelqu'un dans sa voiture demandé à quoi
au moins 50 personnes à 3
ça marche on retrouve d'arriver dans ce
périple her2 et okello relâche tous
heureusement qu'on était à 2 parce que
forcément il ya des moments où on est
fatigué parce qu on est tout le temps en
voyage c'est un voyage de 80 jours c'est
une aventure et forcément c'est quand
même éprouvant parce qu'on choisit
jamais l'heure où on va se coucher ou ne
choisit jamais leur angoisse ne lui ont
choisi pas le lit où on va coucher ma
mère ylmaz a beaucoup reçu il a aussi
pris le temps de donner en aidant des
gens rencontrés en afrique est
aujourd'hui sans grande surprise il
continue à faire le tour du monde
mais cette fois pour raconter son
histoire ici julie jasmin goudreau radio
canada montréal